-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award-nominated
and Tony-winning actress
you know from films
like "Marriage Story,"
"Jojo Rabbit," and
the Marvel cinematic universe.
She stars in the highly
anticipated "Black Widow,"
which is currently in theaters
and available on Disney+
with Premier Access.
Let's take a look.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Engine revving ]
[ Machine-gun fire ]
-Get back.
-Okay, you got a plan,
or should I just stay
Duck and Cover?
-My plan was to drive us away.
-Well, your plan sucks.
[ Tires screech ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Grunts ]
[ Tires screech ]
-You're welcome.
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Scarlett
Johansson.
How are you, Scarlett?
-Hey, Seth. How you doing?
-It is so wonderful to see you
I am doing far better
for having you here.
And it is just so nice
to see your face.
I want to start by addressin
what you've been up to
over the last, you know, 1
difficult months.
Because I heard that one o
the cool things you did
was showed some of your ol
movies to your daughter.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, yeah, well,
I guess it wasn't intentional.
You know, we
went through the series
you know, that we did --
"Indiana Jones."
You know, then we watched
"Back to the Future."
And then we did, of course
naturally, we did "Home Alone.
And I happened to be in
the third "Home Alone" movie
And so I didn't
say anything to her,
because I thought she woul
make a big deal out of it.
Surprisingly --
Not surprisingly, she --
yeah, she didn't pick up
on it right away.
She was like -- had to really --
It was like, "See who that is?
She's like, "What? Where?
Is that you?"
It was like, "It's me.
You know, Mama."
And she was like,
"Oh, okay. Whatever."
Was so into the movie, though,
which is crazy,
because, believe it or not
the plot is a little thin.
You know?
-I feel critics have always said
the third is the best
of the "Home Alone" movies
-Right, yes, they often sa
that the third
of every installment
is the best one.
I think that's right.
-I guess it was --
I mean, that was your
first cinematic universe,
was the "Home Alone"
cinematic universe.
-That is correct.
Little-known fact, yes.
Thanks for bringing it up.
-You had a very --
-I can't wait to see
the spike of views
that "Home Alone 3" now gets
Like, I hope it really,
after this interview, just get
the recognition it deserves.
-I'm guessing it won't take much
more it to spike, you know
[ Laughter ]
One of the things that I was
very lucky to be around fo
was you got married
during the pandemic.
And you had
a very pandemic wedding.
There was
a lot of safety protocols.
Did it, for you --
It must have been disappointin
to have to scale it down.
But did it make it easier in any
way, shape, or form?
-It was a little stressful
But, you know, I think --
At the time,
you know, we really --
Colin, as you know, has --
he's very fortunate.
He has -- His grandparents
are still with him.
And you know, there are,
like, several,
you know, people in their 90
in his family.
He has --
The Josts live forever.
They live so long.
And it's crazy.
And they're lively and vibrant
and they were at our wedding
And so, you know, obviously,
we wanted
to take all the precautions,
every precaution that we could
So we did, you know, people --
we had the masks made.
You know, "Jost 2021."
I mean, it's just weird.
Looking back at the photos -
and everybody had to get teste
100,000 times,
which you guys already do.
And actually half the people
that were at our wedding
also work at NBC.
So, yeah.
It was really --
We made sure to invite
only people that work at NBC
-I still have --
I'm very happy to say,
I still have the Jost mask
Although my wife recently
pointed out to me like,
"I am certain
you have never washed that
And it literally says
"2020" on it,
and you're disgusting."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you know, I mean,
it definitely was
a weird party favor
that could only happen now
-That's very true.
-But you just got to go with it.
Got to go with it.
We were just so happy to see -
Even though it was small and
intimate, it was beautiful
And we were so happy
to see people
that we hadn't seen
in such a long time.
And we just felt very fortunate,
you know,
to be able
to get together like that.
It felt like it was sort o
how it was supposed to be.
Minus face masks.
-It was certainly
one of the highlights
of my year.